are followers as important as people are
playing them up to be right now what if
you had a bunch of followers that didn't
like you
why would they follow you to tell you
every day that they don't like
to tell you that everything you believe
in is [ __ ] terrible that they hate
all of your
everything you've ever done you create
it they hate it
and they hope you don't make it and they
just come to your page to check to make
sure you ain't made it yet
that almost seems to be the chase right
now though is everybody's worried about
followers instead of
crazy quality you see people all the
time who have a
million followers right i'll just say
that because that's the benchmark right
then you look at some [ __ ] that they
post
and that [ __ ] get 5 000 likes but then
you see the girl
with the fat ass who got 8 000 followers
every picture that she post get 34 000
likes and 22 000 comments yo
which position would you rather be in
would you rather have a
a lot of people that don't [ __ ] with you
or a handful of people that support the
[ __ ] out of everything you do
either way i don't want my ass out
yeah i can see why i can see why you i
mean every because that's the thing
about man we couldn't
if we wanted some attention you couldn't
just post your dick print
but i don't matter who you are it's not
you're not gonna attract the type of
women that you would want to see it it'd
be a bunch of
fat [ __ ] and women named tanya they
work at the waffle house like yeah come
get some [ __ ] you're like ugh
sounds like you've been having people
slide to the dms no i'm just saying
like it's like dude it don't matter how
[ __ ] attractive or sexy you think you
are
if you go on that [ __ ] and post some
pictures it's not gonna attract the type
of women that you want to see that [ __ ]
it just don't work like that for us
but you could even be metaphorically and
having your ass out could mean
you post like [ __ ] that's just just
asking for attention
yeah you can tell you can see the
desperation in a lot of people's eyes
bro
social media made a lot of people famous
that don't do [ __ ]
it was the the dislike that made people
like
everything there's a lot of
[ __ ] who just people go
see what the [ __ ] they doing because
they're doing some stupid [ __ ] just to
be like look at this stupid [ __ ]
look at this dumb and this [ __ ] is not
funny look at your boy
that's what i'm saying man hayden
somebody found a way to reverse the hate
with
online [ __ ] in social media yeah found a
whole way to flip the script
so eve the more you dislike some [ __ ]
the further it goes
because when you don't like some [ __ ]
you tell everybody
when you do like some [ __ ] you don't
even want to like it you know leave a
comment
hate can spread just as far as love
that's why i posted that [ __ ] yesterday
bruh it's not the truth that we're
looking for it's the lies that keep us
happy
social media you got to be careful with
that [ __ ] though
seems like you've done a lot of but did
you go to like
india i don't know what is all this
wisdom but i'm just saying
you asked if the followers are important
it's like yeah it's important
if that's if you were in the industry
and you're doing something with them but
if you just got a bunch of followers to
watch you do [ __ ] what the [ __ ] are you
doing you're not getting no money off
that
right but that's the gift in the curse
man
because then you get these followers and
they like you and then you think that
you're somebody right
and then you post a picture of your mom
on mother's day and they roast your mom
or
they just talk about your son like why
is shoes dirty
like who are these people yeah i saw a
video of you
you were like walking in the mall and
this car just rolls up on you and starts
roasting you bro i thought those dudes
were gonna jump out that [ __ ] with
ak-47s
ar-15s these they want to play and [ __ ]
and it's definitely not the time to be
playing
you know what i'm saying like whoa man
[ __ ] i gotta
does that happen a lot and you never
know what you'd never know
you can't do [ __ ] people always peeping
and watching you never know who's
lurking
so you always gotta stay sharp man
you've been in some scary situations
i don't get scared of [ __ ] like that
though the most terrifying situations
that i've
escaped they weren't scary i guess cause
your body just
your mind just going through another
mode or some [ __ ] but like the scariest
[ __ ] that i've ever been through
in my life wasn't even scary going
through it
it's after the fact when you sit back
and you look at what could have happened
that you start overthinking and [ __ ]
like oh [ __ ]
start being prepared for over preparing
for the next time or whatever whatever
what was that you just man there's a
there's a lot of situations where you
end up in
rooms with full of people with
[ __ ] you don't know and you way
to [ __ ] over there and it's one door out
and you start just like all right let me
get the [ __ ] out of here before
that time because some kind of way the
people that i was with have wandered off
and i'm
i don't know where the [ __ ] i am you
know i don't know none of these people
ain't
these [ __ ] extra friendly
mm-hmm
and i guess it's too quiet in here
there's too many [ __ ] looking
at me
it's happened recently i'm just [ __ ]
that happened all the time when i just
have to
realize where the [ __ ] you are and be
aware of your surroundings
you just wandering around some city you
ain't familiar with you ain't noticing
this [ __ ] following you
right you know what i'm saying you don't
you're not even paying attention to this
car that didn't loop by and saw you and
went down and turned around and people
you know what i'm saying you just make
you
you just have to be extra alert because
you never know who knows you and what
they see you as
because you tour all though around the
world now you kind of have more of a
global perspective
on the world which may be informing but
this is the thing though girl
people people can see who you really are
they know who to i'm not saying that
everybody don't have the number call but
it's a it's a certain way that you carry
yourself to let [ __ ] know that
you might be with that [ __ ] too you
might rob me or i might blow your
[ __ ] head off
you don't they can see the pain in your
ass or where you come from or what you
what you made of the way you carry
yourself
you know what i'm saying this
[ __ ] might have might wanted to
rob you at the gas station but he's
saying you
carry yourself in a certain way or you
he heard you say something they'll be
like all right
that's one of us you get what i'm saying
hey hot brother and sister
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath the verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips